all right good afternoon and welcome to
today's richard m carp distinguished
lecture
i'm sandy irani i am the associate
director of the simons institute for the
theory of computing and for those of you
who are not familiar with the simon's
institute
we are the leading international venue
of collaborative research and
theoretical computer science
um simons was established in 2012 with a
very generous grant from the simons
foundation
and the institute brings together the
world's leading researchers in
theoretical computer science and related
fields as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars in the
fellows programs
so the primary aim of the organization
is to explore the use of algorithmic
thinking in science and engineering and
also to study the laws of computing
itself
and before i get started i just wanted
to sort of go over how to ask a question
in today's talk
some of you are physically present here
at calvert lab and others will be
joining through zoom so if you're in the
room you can just raise your hand and
ask a question
those uh listening over zoom can
pose a question through the q a and i'll
be monitoring that throughout the talk
so we established the richard m carp
distinguished lecture series to
celebrate the role of simon's institute
director uh foundational director dick
carp and to celebrate dick's many uh
contributions to the field of
theoretical computer science
formulating central problems and his
stunning array of results in
computational complexity and algorithms
this features this series features
visionary leaders in theoretical
computer science and is geared towards a
general scientific audience and so we're
grateful to the many contributors to the
richard m carp fund who have made this
series possible
so i'm really excited today to welcome
nicole morlika to give um the talk
and uh nicole is a senior principal
researcher at microsoft research new
england where she leads the economics
and computational group
she's also the chair of sig econ the acm
special interest group on economics and
nicole received her bachelor of science
masters of engineering and phd in
theoretical computer science from mit
and later joined microsoft new england
in 2012.
nicole's research interest is in the
design and operation of
socio techno
technical systems so she uses tools and
modeling concepts from theoretical
computer science
and economics in with the goal of
explaining predicting
and shaping behavioral patterns in
online and offline systems markets and
games nicole is best known for her work
on social networks matching markets and
mechanism design
she's also the recipient of a number of
fellowships and awards including the
sloan fellowship the microsoft faculty
fellowship and the nsf career award so
her talk today is entitled birds of a
feather flock together how homophily
leads to segregation inequality and
inefficiency and what we can do about it
so please join me in welcoming nicole
great thanks for the
thanks for the introduction um so what
i'd like to talk to you today about
today is homophily and homophily is this
idea that we all tend to seek out
relationships with people that are
similar to
us right so you look for friends with
which you share common traits and
characteristics and i think this is a
very intuitive idea if you look around
at your own friend groups but it's also
well documented in uh in data so this uh
here is a graph you can find this graph
in the wonderful popular science book
the human network by one of my
co-authors matt jackson
and what this graph is demonstrating is
the social network of a high school and
each node here is a student there's an
edge between two students if they have
engaged in more than three activities
together and the nodes are colored
according to the race of the student so
the blue notes here are black students
the yellow nodes are white students and
then there's a you know spattering of
other races intertwined in here as well
and what uh you can see visually here is
that the
black students tend to have more black
friends than than white friends and the
white students tend to have more white
friends than black friends that is
there's a natural tendency towards
homophobia in this network their
network kind of
segregates in a sense and so why should
we care about this phenomenon i'm gonna
i'm gonna sort of take this phenomenon
as a fact throughout this talk and try
to think about how it impacts this is a
very local phenomenon right it's like my
personal choices about who to befriend i
want to see how that impacts global
societal level uh
outcomes
and
the first half of the talk i will
discuss the impact of segregation on
uh the impact of homophily on
segregation in geographical networks or
in housing markets if you like so this
is a graph of boston which is where i'm
from um and
here this is based on the 2010 census
data there's a
dot color for each
in each geographical area according to
the race of the individual that lives
there so blue is white
green is black and so on and what you'll
see is that the the city is largely
segregated there's areas where there's a
lot of
white residents there's areas that are
mostly black and hispanic there's
there's a chinatown which is
predominantly red um
and so and and yet there there is some
amount of integration as well uh in
certain neighborhoods and so the the
question is
does homophily these sort of very local
preferences about who your individual
friends are lead to this kind of
city-wide segregation and so we'll
discuss that in the first half of the
talk
and then in the second half of the talk
i want to discuss the impact of
homophily on labor markets in particular
the inequality in labor markets and how
it perpetuates over time in the form of
immobility
and
it will also see that it surprisingly
perhaps has implications for the
productivity of the economy as well so
even if you don't care about equity from
a like outcome perspective if you're a
utilitarian and you care about welfare
uh this you should also care about this
impact and so uh here's again some data
just to demonstrate that that this
phenomenon exists in society there's of
course many many reasons for this um but
we'll see that homophily
also can be one driver in these sorts of
outcomes and so this graph shows you the
disparity in employment rates between
white and black men and how that uh
persists over time you can find many
similar plots in the u.s bureau of labor
statistics
so let me jump right into talking to you
about homophily and its impact on
housing markets
this literature was really initiated in
the 60s by
the
nobel prize-winning economist thomas
shelling who wanted to study this idea
that i've been discussing with you that
these very micro motives as he called
them these individual preferences for my
very local neighborhood could have macro
effects
and
uh shelling
focused primarily on uh lattices which
you could think of as being rough
approximations to the geographies we see
in cities uh he studied a
one-dimensional lattice and a
two-dimensional lattice as i've drawn on
the slide here so each point on this
lattice is you can think of it as being
a house
and in each house lives a person who is
one of two types and throughout this
talk i'll be discussing populations with
two types of agents represented by
uh green triangles and blue circles
so initially maybe the city is
pretty uh integrated so every type every
house is occupied by a type with equal
probability and but nonetheless
people have these sort of micro motives
they have a preference to be in a
neighborhood they want their local
neighborhood to look similar to them to
have a lot of people of their type so
the neighborhood of an individual is
defined to be
all the houses that are within some
distance of that individual so i
will keep w as the parameter for the
size of the neighborhood and
then
the node is going to decide whether
they're happy or not
based on the composition of this
neighborhood
so here we see that the center note this
center green triangle in the slide uh
has a neighborhood represented by that
blue diamond and
the node will look around at the local
neighborhood and realize well you know
there's five triangles and eight circles
and then decide is
uh being
in a five-eighths minority sufficient
for me to be happy or not and uh so
that's going to depend on this what we
call tolerance parameter tau tao equals
a half would mean that i just don't want
to be a minority i'm happy so long as
i'm not a minority tao less than a half
means you're okay being a minority so
long as it's not
smaller than a tau minority
um
and
then
what's gonna happen in the dynamics is
that nodes that are unhappy are gonna
move
and there's two sort of dynamics by
which moving might happen you could
imagine if you think of a city as a
closed system then in order for you to
move you need somebody else to move so
you need to like find someone to swap
houses with this is the swapping dynamic
we talked about this in the boot camp in
the context of one-dimensional shelling
dynamics
and realize that it's quite close to the
flipping dynamic today i'll focus on the
flipping dynamic which you could think
of as more of an open city kind of
dynamic where if you're unhappy
in a as a minority in boston you're
going to move to new york and somebody
from you know somebody else from the
outside world will move to boston and so
this is represented by just flipping the
color of the note if they're unhappy
um but at the high level what's
happening here is that unhappy nodes are
going to change color
and the question is whether these micro
motives the fact that i don't want to be
too small of a minority in my local
neighborhood can have macro impacts
just to summarize the sort of main
parameters but you don't really need to
remember
many symbols i'm going to try and do
most of this talk without much math we
have the neighborhood size w that's how
wide of a neighborhood i'm sensitive to
right
like who i consider to be a neighbor
it's anyone living within uh distance w
of me we have the size of the society
that's how many people live in the city
and and we have a tolerance parameter
tau how willing i am to be a minority
and so let's sort of investigate
how these dynamics play out in a network
so here i have a simulation uh this is
on a society of 750 squared people and
the neighborhoods are of size 5 and the
tolerance perimeter is 0.5 so this this
is i uh
the situation in which i simply don't
want to be a minority at all i'm
intolerant of being in a minority i'm
happy to have neighbors of other color
right but i don't want to be a minority
so what's going to happen
as we run the dynamic
okay so i'm playing the movie now and
you can see that uh people are moving
around in this in this square trying to
find they're flipping colors to try and
be become happy and over time you start
to see these shapes emerge oh these blue
and red shapes but they're kind of like
noodle-like and intertwined in funny
patterns right and so that this is a
simulation but
the question that i want to explore in
the first half of this talk is whether
we can say prove anything quantitative
about the patterns that arise from this
type of dynamic
um
so
what sort of quantitative things might i
hope to say to remind you this is the
fully tolerant case nobody's going to
move right so we just stay with whatever
the initial configuration was which was
complete integration and for this sort
of critical tolerance
0.5 we're going to end up with some
picture which maybe looks like that
and uh how am i going to explain that
the left is more segregated than the
right the measure of segregation that i
choose to study is the radius of the
largest monochromatic region containing
a random note
okay so
you might be in if you're you know you
have a very big ball around you that's
all blue
as a as a blue note then then that's
a very segregated neighborhood if you
have a very small region like in this
picture then it's a very integrated
society
and what we
saw so remember i just showed you a
bunch of simulations on a 2d lattice you
can also talk about all of this on a 1d
lattice and what we saw in the boot camp
was that uh for the one dimensional
lattice at this critical threshold of a
half there's actually not all that much
segregation in the society right so we
argued that the segregated neighborhoods
have size something like i showed you
ordered w squared but uh order w is is
known actually that order w is a
follow-up paper but
you know the point here being that it's
something polynomial in w so it's it's
small it's like on the order of the
neighborhood to neighborhood it's it's a
very nice segregated a nice uh
integrated city where you have little
ethnic enclaves you have your chinatown
and your little italy and so on right
um so
that's going to happen with this
critical tolerance of a half
and
it's interesting to think about why in
the boot camp we explored the proof of
this fact and saw that the reason that
you're getting these kinds of
you know monochromatic neighborhoods
that are well distributed throughout the
city is because the individuals are you
know initially almost everybody was
unhappy and everybody wanted to move
around
and so long so neighborhoods with a
slight imbalance are going to very
quickly become monochromatic and then
there they become immune to immigration
from the outside and in particular as
soon as you get a length w
monochromatic neighborhood you're
completely stable with respect to the
dynamics and since this is happening
very frequently all over the place you
get a lot of these
order w length neighborhoods
so that's what we saw um
about the critical threshold last week
but uh you might and many of you asked
me what happens if we change this
tolerance parameter what if i insist on
being a majority or what if i don't care
at all about my neighborhood so can we
describe the pattern of segregation we
get as we
perturb as we range across all tolerance
parameters in society and so this
follow-up paper studied this question uh
showing and uh there's the region of
which when people insist on being in a
majority um and there
the dynamics are a little bit funny but
for the definition they chose you get
total segregation i'm going to not focus
on that at all
and for
small enough
tolerance so like when i don't care at
all about my neighborhood or i'm happy
being a very tiny minority you can
imagine that
nobody's got not very many people are
going to move and so you should expect
there to be a very small
amount of segregation in the society
and what was very interesting is that
there's this
uh sort of threshold around a third
which says that if there are more than a
third of the people like if i insist on
being a
you know i'm happy to be a minority but
i don't want to be too small a minority
i need like
.35 people to be similar to me
then
what happens is you get
worse results you get exponential and w
segregation
so we started you know when people are
super tolerant we get a lot of
integration when people are
happy to just not be a minority we get
integration but when people are just a
little bit tolerant
we get exponential segregation
um
and in fact uh this curve is is
decreasing as you get towards one half
so if you think as a planner about maybe
trying to get people a little bit more
tolerant if you can only move this tau
by a little bit just go a little bit
this way you actually get worse
segregation as a result
so what i'd like to do today is tell you
about
that results
in the 2d settings so this is a
follow-up paper uh with bobby kleinberg
brandon lucier and
morteza sadi moghadam
and so in this this paper we wanted to
study these dynamics in a
two-dimensional lattice and this is i
think a more challenging mathematical
problem than the one-dimensional lattice
because these sorts of stable structures
that we explored in the one-dimensional
case if you happen to come to my
bootcamp lecture are harder to define in
the two-dimensional case so these
firewalls i had been talking about are
harder to
define in the two-dimensional setting
um
and so
we had to leverage different techniques
and in fact if you're looking for
open questions to work on nobody's been
able to solve the case of tau equal to
one-half for the two-dimensional lattice
but what i'm going to tell you about is
the tau the subcritical tolerance tau
slightly less than one-half and what
we're going to see is in the as in the
1d case this 2d sub-critical tolerance
regime gives you exponential segregation
and the rationale the reason i'm
interested in this and i'll emphasize
this again at the end is i think by
looking at the theoretical mechanism by
which this happens we can start to
uh devise policies to address it and so
it's it's important to understand
how the thing how how the outcome is is
achieved in order to try and reverse it
um and the sort of high level idea i'll
delve into the details a tiny bit but
the high level idea is that uh the way
this happens is that
you know initially everybody's in a
almost
balanced neighborhood and so almost
everybody's fine with that right because
you're happy to be a minority so long as
it's not too small of a minority so by
law of large numbers your neighborhood's
going to be fairly mixed and you're
going to be fairly happy
but there's going to be rare cases where
the
segregation of your neighborhood is
uh
like a standard deviation away from
what's you expect and in those rare
cases the minority is very unhappy and
they're going to move out and this is
going to create a wave of immigration
that's just going to wash over all those
complacent people and the only thing
that can stop this wave of immigration
is a wave of immigration of the opposite
color but since the the origins of these
waves are exponentially far apart you're
going to get exponential segregation
so let me
go through that in a little bit more
pictorial
or like a little bit more uh detail on
the slides
to
emphasize this point this is just to
start a simulation of what happens in
what this subcritical regime so this is
a simulation for tau equals 0.36 and you
can see these are different snapshots in
time you can see that it starts out well
it starts out integrated but
very early on you start getting bubbles
of different colors and these bubbles
just kind of grow and grow and grow
until in the converged state you get a
lot of segregation
so the specific theorem i'm not going to
prove
use any math in this talk so i'm not
going to prove these these exact form of
this uh segregation to you but the
theorem that we were able to state was
that you're going to
end up with segregation that's
exponential in the neighborhood size
so long as
the tolerance is sufficiently
close to one-half but less than one-half
okay so let me
give you a very high-level rationale for
how this proof works which is basically
i already told you in the initial slide
but i'll repeat
with slightly more detail
so now it's the opposite that's when the
axle gets smaller
[Music]
if you get a little bit more tolerance
tolerant
oh it's the center
yeah so christian is pointing out that
as you get more tolerant that is epsilon
gets smaller
then
uh your segregation is getting worse
so long as you're less than a half
um
so
here's a rationale for it in pictures we
have
in the beginning
as i said most neighborhoods are pretty
mixed that is most neighborhoods look
like this they're about half circle half
triangle
as time
however there are also in the beginning
a few
neighborhoods that are very segregated
just because of the initial conditions
right so you get a few neighborhoods
that look like this they're almost
monochromatic
and
in the
uh what i'll call complacent
neighborhoods the ones that are pretty
mixed everybody's fine
you know like i might be a minority but
that's okay everyone's fine in the
complacent neighborhoods in the agitated
neighborhoods
this green triangles the minority type
are very unhappy and they really want to
leave
and so they're they're going to leave
and what you should be thinking about is
what happens when an agitated
neighborhood a butt's a complacent one
what's going to happen to
the
happiness of all these people on the
boundary
and so a back of the envelope
calculation let's let's focus in on
uh
minority type on the boundary somebody
who's a minority according to the
invading agitated neighborhood this guy
is going to have well in the north
east
a hundred percent or nearly 100
of the neighbors are going to be of the
opposite type right
and in the southwest
well this neighborhood is close to
uniformly random so
20 you know half of these guys are going
to be of the same type
and so
when you add these up you see that that
guy has 75 of their neighbors
of the opposite type so this person
because we said the tolerance parameter
was 0.36 this person is unhappy and so
this this back of the envelope
calculation should
start to make you think that maybe
somewhere around a quarter you know
there might be some kind of like if
certainly if the tolerance was uh that
i'm happy to be in a quarter minority
then maybe these things wouldn't take
over right and if i'm
uh
somewhere closer then these things are
going to invade okay so fine so these
monochromatic neighborhoods are invading
but that doesn't yet prove the result
that the monochromatic neighborhoods
grow exponentially large because
you know there could be another
invading monochromatic neighborhood
of the opposite type and when when two
agitated things come up when two waves
of immigration
hit
you're gonna they're gonna stop right
so we have to worry about that and so
they all of the like you know
mathematical effort in the proof goes
into showing that
these these things because they're
exponentially far apart for any random
node we can draw an exponentially big
circle around it
and in this inner circle there will be
exactly one
monochromatic neighborhood
or like area that's in the initial
configuration very close to
monochromatic and no others and then
there's a buffer zone
so in this in the ring there there's a
buffer zone where everybody's complacent
and as a result this
guy is going to grow and will be
buffered from invaders from the outside
by this ring and so it will have
sufficient time to overtake
the region that includes the star
so that's a high level
explanation of the proof
of this
result
if you want details i'll refer you to
the paper as this is a high level
lecture so i'm not going to get into the
math
in particular
but uh let me let me recap here which is
that the what have we learned from
exploring this
this setting we've learned that okay
weak preferences for homophily which we
take as a fact that exists in this world
can cause
uh drastic geographical segregation in
housing markets
um and that
these you know so so that that's the
mathematical fact that we proved
and why do i think that's interesting
because i believe that by understanding
the theoretical groundings of societal
facts like that
it'll it
will give us an idea about the mechanism
that causes it and understanding this
mechanism is important to developing
policies that address it and so in this
case what we learned was that the
mechanism that happens here the reason
that these
local preferences have these global
impacts is because we get these
homogeneous neighborhoods that are
infiltrating the integrated ones
creating waves of immigration and so
this naturally points to potential
policies to address it for example you
could consider subsidizing houses in
integrated neighborhoods so like maybe
we could just pay people to stay put and
these would just kind of form barriers
that would resist the wave of
immigration of the uh segregated
neighborhood
so um
i i put a question mark here because
this is not something that i've analyzed
and and so i think this is another
interesting direction for future
research thinking about policies that
that create integrated cities
and one idea here is subsidized housing
another idea is sort of natural
maybe natural geographical barriers in
cities that might also stop these ways
of
immigration but the high level point
here is that because we now know this
mechanism we can start to think about
ways to
to kill it
okay
um so that's that's the what i wanted to
tell you about
homophily and housing markets and now
i'd like to switch to discussing
homophily and labor markets
uh yeah
yeah quick question on the previous
slide right so
the factor tau indicates
the preference try to stay in
a segregated market or not right yes
is there a way to also factor in say
aspirations like you know because i'm
assuming some people might have
aspirations to prefer this but aspire to
move somewhere else
[Music]
i might have a utility function that
specifies that i prefer integrated
segregated neighborhoods right
for a different segregated neighborhood
different segregated neighborhood than
mine okay so uh the question is about
changing the preferences of the
individuals in this market and you could
imagine different ways to protect the
preferences one of them might be
um
that i i
like my preferences were very binary in
the model right i either was happy or
unhappy and if i was unhappy i was going
to move but you could have
a
smoother utility function that says that
i'm
you know like more or less happy
depending on the composition of my
neighborhood and my ideal point might
not even be
at
like i might not always prefer more
segregated neighborhoods i might even
prefer
somewhat mixed neighborhoods so this
kind of thing uh has been looked at and
gets similar results to this
um
i i don't know the
like i can maybe offline give you some
citations to
specific literature or you could look
online
uh the other question was what if people
just have a innate preference for
certain
neighborhoods maybe like i want to live
near i don't know the mountains because
i like hiking all right then i think
this would help
again i haven't seen this result studied
but intuitively because i can now think
about this mechanism that we've unveiled
this would help uh sort of stem that
flow
yes
but here it looks like you're looking at
similarity with respect to like one
color right yeah one dimension is there
anything like what if there's like
you're okay with people similarly
so the question was about the definition
of homophily here i'm assuming every
individual has a single type
and that i am going to
want to live in people that have types
that are similar to mine
i live in neighborhoods with people that
have types that are similar to mine but
what if types i mean we're all much more
multi-dimensional than that so what if
types uh have some
you know that there's a vector of types
and every individual is a vector of
types i
haven't i started talking about this
with some people at simon's i haven't
seen
uh research on that um
that i'm aware of but like i you could
imagine that this
might help uh like
create integration and now you have to
think about uh also what your utility
function is because if i match on one
dimension
versus two dimensions am i happy are
matching on two and like so there's some
sort of modeling questions that you have
to iron out there but i do think that's
an interesting direction
yeah
uh what happens if uh red and blue has
different towel parameters
okay that's a great question um the
question was what if red and blue have
different tau parameters this was
actually studied by that
was group that i cited and i i can give
you a reference to that the the sort of
idea here is that there's some evidence
that
certain types are more tolerant of being
a minority than other types and in
particular maybe if they're already a
minority in the population
um so that paper looked at
what if we fix the two types to be 50 50
but we say one type has is more tolerant
than the other type and then you can see
that uh
you get segregation in these settings
if the tolerance parameters are in
certain regimes and i actually have a
slide that i hid for sake of time that
that sort of plots this two-dimensional
space um but
the only points on the diagonal which is
when we have the same tiles that are
known are the ones i just presented
so the question is whether the process
can be periodic uh so
with either the flip or stop dynamics
for the towel less than one half regime
the process always converges and there's
a
sort of
potential function argument that you can
use to show that uh but for tau greater
than one half and this is
one reason i said less about it um
you can imagine that there's
configurations that
people are unhappy but they just can't
find anyone to swap it
and so
i guess then then it becomes a question
of how do you model that like do you let
them swap with someone who's happy like
you allow with pareto improvements then
you might not get convergent
yeah
so it seems that this mechanism really
rely something
housing complex for
mainly for the
black people
you have another sort of suburban area
they put the white ones in
so
originally the
pointing out that my mechanism
and my uh analysis relies heavily on the
assumption that
uh people are
initially uh distributed
uniformly um
and indeed if you like
so
you could ask this the question i guess
is what if
maybe a more realistic assumption in
cities is that some areas are
uh like their immigrants come to new
york city and they move into like you
know the lower east side if they're
italian or whatever it is right and so
like if that's the case then how do you
uh think about what would happen like
what happens to this mechanism and
certainly if those
ethnic enclaves are strong enough
they're not going to they can then
resist these waves of immigration so i
think the answer is it's going to depend
on how you you model this one way to
view this result is that like this ideal
of full integration
if that's the ideal is
uh unsustainable without some
sort of
policies or
mechanisms to to stabilize it
um
i wanted to see if there's any questions
on zoom so i don't know where to look to
see you guys
um but please ask questions on zoom i'd
be happy to address them
yeah
what are the size of the buffer
relative to
okay yeah so now we're getting into
details of the proof which is i
i'm going to draw two circles one one is
large like large enough but not too
large such that i get exactly one of
these
uh guys that's gonna like create a wave
of immigration and the other is a buffer
making sure nobody from the outside
impacts me um
and the ratio of the sizes of these is
polynomial and w but like i i want to
maybe stay away from the details of the
math i'd be happy to
go through that with you offline if
you're
interested
i think in the interest of time i might
move on to my second i'm happy to
discuss this more in the q a after the
talk
but i would like to get a chance to tell
you about homophily and labor markets
and so
this is now
a different model but i think it's
interesting and part of this talk
because it has one of those same drivers
which is homophily and you might be
looking at this and thinking
well homophily you defined as being
about social networks what do labor
markets have to do with social networks
and to answer that i'll reference frank
robinson who was a baseball player and
he said i've never seen baseball
advertised for a job and i've never
heard of whites applying for a job i
mean there's an old boy network and it's
lily white and so what's emphasized here
is that
you know jobs are acquired through
networks and in particular in uh this is
going to be through referrals in my
model uh and that these networks these
referral networks
are um
very haemophilus so
we get a lot of uh
like in the net in the baseball case
all the employed workers were white and
they were all uh referring white people
um and so that's anecdotal of course but
there's a lot of research documenting
that referrals are important for getting
jobs so there's a a bunch of survey
literature by sociologists showing that
so for example topa in 2011 showed that
over 50 of jobs are found through
referrals and this has been extended to
labor markets of all different sorts of
skill levels and so it's true of call
center employees it's true of university
presidents um
and and so
uh referrals are important for getting
jobs
there you might like you know that this
isn't a causal study but there's this
other study that i think is very
beautiful and if you're interested in
reading some of the empirical work in
this space and this is a paper that
looked at the random assignment of
soldiers to units in world war one and
then studied the employment outcomes of
the soldiers after the war and what they
found was that uh having been assigned
randomly remember to a unit
because of the draft
having been assigned randomly to a unit
where your peers ended up more employed
increased your own employment chances by
0.8
um and so that suggests that there's
some at least some kind of network
effect even if it's not referrals
there's some kind of network effect
where having
highly employed friends improves your
chances of employment
so
okay referral networks matter then you
might ask
uh what is the impact of referral
networks right referrals are a very sort
of local thing again what's the impact
on the overall labor market and sort of
global statistics perspective and uh
we'll see in the context of a model that
i'll define for you that the impact of
these referral networks is to uh there's
going to be inequality if they're
if workers workers with referrals end up
being advantaged so if the referrals are
going mostly to the lilly white old boys
network then you're going to get
inequality in who you hire
there's also going to be immobility in
the
in that this inequality is perpetuated
across generations
and
surprisingly it i think referral
networks are going to have an impact on
productivity because referrals are
actually good for the economy because
what does a referral do it lets the firm
have an extra chance to screen a
candidate before they make a hiring
decision and so we'll see that referrals
are good for the economy so they
increase productivity but
referral networks with more equality are
better at increasing productivity
so that'll be that'll be the takeaway
so
let me start by introducing the model i
have a set of firms and a set of workers
i'm going to assume that i have more
workers than firms there's going to be
some unemployment in this economy the
workers again are of two types
you can think about this as men and
women or something we have the blue
circles and the green triangles
and
those types are
publicly observable but uh otherwise the
workers are ex-ante identical
um the workers
have
values of course so each worker
generates a
potentially different value for the firm
but these values are not uh
correlated with the types in particular
the values are drawn from some
iid from some known distribution after
okay
now uh the
firms are going to hire workers from the
population and when they hire a worker
they generate some value which the
worker generates some value which is
equal to
her her
quality as a work or her vi
uh
so then in the economy i'm going to have
a set of firms that have some employees
and some unemployed people and this is
what's happening say currently today but
firms are long-lived and people are
short-lived so all these guys are going
to retire and unemployed ones are going
to die poor and hungry um and so the
firms need new workers for the next
generation
and so we assume that there's some next
period employees next period workers and
the firms want to hire
from these next period workers to
continue their business
so how do they hire well
they can hire from referrals
in a referral each current employee is
going to refer a next period worker
let's assume for a moment that
the firms have exactly one employee and
each employee refers exactly one next
period worker
and the the network the friend network
here is that all blues are friends with
each other and all greens are friends
with each other
and so the blues are going to pick a
person at random from among the blues to
refer the queens pick a person at random
from among the greens to refer
generating some referral network that
looks something like this
um this this can be relaxed to more
interesting social networks and and much
of what i say will go through but this
is this is easier to think about
so this is how
the firms get referrals
and now what is the
value of a referral um well it gives the
firm a chance to hire an extra chance to
hire so the firm is the strategic
decision of the firm now is to decide
whether to hire the referred worker or
hire a random worker that's pulled from
the pool of unemployed people right
and what's
not valuable about referred workers
we're going to assume that there is a
screening effect here that is that the
sperm when they get a referral they are
also told the value of that worker
right so they get to see the value of
the worker that they're referred to
before they make an offer whereas if
they hire from the pool of unemployed
workers they don't see the value they
have to hire the person employ them for
a while until they learn the value
this is
you know perhaps an extreme uh
assumption but it's
well documented that firms have more
information about referrals and that's
why
uh employees hired through referrals
tend to be more productive than those uh
hired on the open market
and so we've just taken this this
assumption to the extreme but you could
imagine relaxing that
um
so in order to understand
the now i'd like to discuss what are
firms how are they going to hire like
they have a choice to make care do i
hire my referred worker or do i go to
this uh
unemployed pool
and in order to understand that
we have to think through what's called
the lemons effect um
in job markets and labor markets so
you've probably if you've tried ever
tried to buy a used car you've probably
heard about lemons they're like the cars
that don't work as well as you were
promised and and uh
there's there's
uh
lemon laws and whatnot so that there's
there's lemons in many markets in the
context of labor markets uh lemons were
first explored by montgomery in 1991 in
a model different than ours but somewhat
similar
and then a lot of empirical economists
and sociologists have gone on to
document that this effect exists in
labor markets so what is the lemon
effect it's the idea that
if a firm has a referred worker
then they might
like look at that person see their value
and decide not to hire them why would
they decide not to hire them they would
not hire them because their value is low
right and so if a work a firm looks at a
next period worker decides not to hire
her because her value is low
what happens to that worker she's going
to enter the pool of unemployed and wait
for a random off uh you know to be that
lucky person that's picked from the pool
of unemployed and get hired by the next
firm
and so this worker we call her a lemon
because when she enters this pool of
unemployed workers
the effect that she has is to pull down
the average value of unemployed workers
so the lemon's effect here is that the
average value of unemployed workers in
the pool is smaller than the average
value of workers in the population
overall
okay
and this is key to understanding the
equilibrium because
what the you know the firm has two
choices i can hire the referred worker
or i can hire from the pool and clearly
i want to hire the referred worker if
they're better than the average value in
the pool
so that's going to be the equilibrium
the firms are going to hire the referred
worker if they're better than the
average value in the pool
and now the average value in the pool is
in fact the solution to some fixed point
equation because this is endogenous
based on the
threshold the strategies of the firms
which can be characterized by this
threshold
um and so
you can can solve some fixed point
equation to to understand what this
looks like it's it's not that important
the point is that there's some
endogenous hiring threshold and firms
are going to hire the referred worker if
they pass that threshold otherwise if
they don't pass that threshold they
throw them back in the pool which is the
right choice for that individual firm
but then imposes an externality on the
market as a whole because other firms
might now hire that limit um and so they
could also potentially fail to hire if
they all go after the same worker um and
then uh like there's a competition for
that worker and that worker ends up in
the pool i mean that that firm ends up
hiring from the pool as well
uh and so you can already see that
there's this inequality in the labor
market the fact that even though 50
percent of the population is circles but
only
but two-thirds of them are employed is
going to lead to inequality in the
future period
and that's because
if there's an uncharacteristically large
portion of blue
employees then there's going to be an
uncharacteristically large fraction of
referrals to blue next period workers
because of the homophobia in the
referral network and so
um because referred workers get more
offers on average it means that the next
period is also going to be have more
blue workers than green workers
now if you're
listening closely you'll say but wait a
minute the
pool is going to you know it's the
there's 50 50 in the population overall
so if
if
more blues are higher on the referral
market there will be more greens in the
pool so that when you pull at random
from the pool you're more likely to hire
a minority or
according to employment the
disadvantaged group and so that causes
this inequality to attenuate over time
what is interesting is that this
inequality could perpetuate indefinitely
if uh
you have other sort of tweaks to the
model that seem very realistic like
maybe you need to invest in education in
order to attain your value as a worker
and then if greens wake up and realize
that they're not going to get very many
referrals because there's a
despair
like
too few greens on the in the employment
market they might find it not valuable
to invest and then this could cause the
inequality to perpetuate over time yes
better hiring off the green workers
so the question is if you're better
hiring green workers um so we are
assuming that the firms are myopic or
maybe there's laws that discourage me
from
uh
picking types uh if i the reason that
green workers are actually good for a
firm better than just their value is
that they have downstream value right
because
hiring a green worker means that i'm
less likely to encounter competition in
a refer for a referral in the future is
that what you were thinking about
oh and okay so the other that's about
hiring green workers on the referral
market and i'm assuming that away
because uh
they're i'm assuming firms are myopic
i'm only trying to optimize my next
period utility
um but there's also a thing about the
unemployed pool which is that and this
is
uh something that i think is actually
pretty nice too which is that
the
in the unemployed pool the greens are
less likely to be lemons because they
had less referrals so in fact the
minority type in the unemployed pool is
actually more productive than the
majority type you would rather hire the
minority type in this model than the
majority type
i am assuming that search in the pool is
very expensive and so you just get your
one draw and you can't draw again um
but indeed if you could you and this
this would attenuate further attenuate
this problem you would prefer to hire
the minority type because they're more
likely to have a high value
so
all right
and by the way on the flip side the
employed blues are more likely to have a
high value so if you do some bad
economics and you say you can conclude
that blues are more you only study the
productivity of hired people you could
accidentally infer that the
majority type is more productive even
though that's not true in the model
um so anyway this is this is all about
inequality there's lots of interesting
like
nuances here uh but the one that
interested me perhaps the most is
uh this idea that inequality in this
model actually also drives an efficiency
in the market overall so why is that
you can look at two different networks
here's the more equal one on the top and
the less
sorry the more inequal one on the top
and the less an equal one on the bottom
so here we have blues are 50 of the
population but hold two-thirds of the
jobs here the blues are 50 of the
population and hold 50 percent of the
jobs what's the impact on the referral
network
well
here you have
50 of the referrals are being
distributed
sorry two-thirds of the referrals are
being distributed to only 50 percent of
the population
among the blues and one third of the
referrals are be distributed to the
other 50 of the population and so as a
result you're gonna have more people
with multiple referrals up here and
simultaneously more people with no
referrals
when the
uh just when the network is more in
unequal
so what's that imply for the economy
well remember
referrals offer this sort of screening
effect because you can look at the value
of the employee before you hire them and
so when we have
more inequality there's more people that
aren't screened
because they've never got a referral to
begin with so
that's one effect
but also simultaneously a lot of these
people that weren't looked at had high
value they ended up in the pool and they
dragged the value of the pool up thereby
lessening the lemons effect making the
average value of the unemployed people
closer to the value of the population
overall
and this first effect is bad for
productivity right like uh
firms
if they are able if they're screening
less they're less likely to catch those
high valued workers
whereas the second effect here is good
for productivity
and
that's because this externality that
me
rejecting somebody of low value
that there's less of that right when i
hire at random from the pool i'm more
likely to get a good worker
and so what we were able to prove is
that the first effect always dominates
the second and hence employment rate
ratios that are closer to being
population balanced strictly improve
productivity
so what could we do about this and in
this case
i
did try to study a particular policy in
particular i wanted to look at
affirmative action as a way to address
this
uh
productivity hit and inequality in the
social networks and there's many ways
you can imagine implementing affirmative
action i know that this is kind of like
a word from the 90s but um i think it
still exists a lot today sweet
scandinavian countries require 40 of
their board members to be women of
publicly traded companies which i think
is amazing
uh colleges often are have my
scholarships for minorities grad
students so we're basically subsidizing
the minority type uh the hiring of the
minority type
we could also potentially require firms
to interview more broadly and and this
would require me to be able to make
decisions based on type but i could if
i'm able to do that i could require
firms to interview the minority type
this happens at microsoft we're required
to have a diverse slate for
any position above a certain
uh hiring level uh and so that
gets the at least the foot in the door
for these greens
um and so on but basically the overall
impact of any of these is to increase
green employment
so yeah
if i understood the mechanism so one
other thing that you could do is insist
so sid is asking if i couldn't like just
break the homophily i could insist that
you're only allowed to give me a
referral of the other type i'm taking in
this talk homophobically as a kind of
fact about the world that i'm not able
to manipulate you just don't have
friends of the other type i i'm not
going to have time but i i i have a
comment
that i prepared that i probably won't
get to about why even if
there's no racism or hatred in society
there's actually a rational reason for
us to
exhibit haemophilus preferences and so
i'm taking that as fixed but certainly
that could be one thing and that's
actually something i would love to
suggest to linkedin which is that uh
they create a lot of these like
mentorship programs that cross
racial boundaries
um
so
how do we
think about the impact of increasing
green employment you might say well of
course if you increase green employment
that's got to be good for greens right
in the next generation so i increase
green employment in the current period
what impact does it have on the next
period and
in fact you can
cook up examples where there could
actually be a perverse effect and this
is driven again by that lemons thing i
was talking about so here um
you could imagine that
you start with a very unequal population
maybe 0.3 employees are green and you
consider increasing them as as you
increase the current green employment
you have to think about what happens to
where people are being hired from
because remember the referral market is
disproportionately blue and the
pool is disproportionately green and at
very unequal employment rates there's
not so much hiring happening on the
referral market because i mean there
aren't that many referrals to start with
so there's a bunch of hiring happening
in the pool
but as we increase the mass of green
workers that are employed we get more
hiring um
we we change the hiring threshold
because we get more lemons right so we
have more referrals we get more lemons
and so the quality of the pool decreases
and it could suddenly jump
and
uh or like suddenly drop the quality of
the pool causing the hiring on the
referral market to jump when we get near
these boundaries in this example um we
have a lot of mass on a value of one
type and that's why this
this jump happens but you could do this
with continuous values as well and so as
a result you might get that the
uh next period employment but that
because you know all of a sudden when
you increased green
uh
employment in the current
uh economy the next period employment
was
basically all drawn from the referral
market where blues are favored this
could harm the next generation
so this is this is a thing to be wary of
but
in fact we can show that affirmative
action if it
doesn't sort of jump over those cliffs
is going to basically always work and if
it's moderate enough it's going to in
fact always improve total production in
all future periods so it's not only good
for equality for speeding up this
convergence to
equal labor markets but it's also good
for productivity
and so to recap what we've learned in
this section of the talk is that
homophily and referral networks
can cause
labor markets to perpetuate inequality
and reduce productivity so this might be
a thing that we want to address
again the reason i care about doing the
theory is because i feel like doing the
theory illuminates mechanisms
that uh drive the theoretical result
that we can then try to address with
policy and so the mechanism that we had
here was this concentration and who gets
referrals that inequality causes a
concentration who gets referrals and
what we really want to do is spread out
the referrals evenly around the
population and sid suggested one way to
do this is to get people to refer people
of the other type
another way to do this is with
affirmative action
uh you could imagine we explore in the
paper uh other ways to
to also increase inequality like having
more flexible firing policies or
another i think interesting one for this
crowd is that if you have an online
market like linkedin you could imagine
creating policies around the search in
the pool so someone also brought this up
that like you i think elon said you'd
rather get greens from the pool in fact
what you want is to get people that were
not already rejected so you can imagine
some kind of uh algorithm implemented in
online labor markets that tries to give
everybody
a a chance right like you give
every
when somebody asks for a draw for an
employee you try to pick people that
haven't yet been looked at
um so
i had hoped to tell you about rational
explanations for homophily i'm not going
to get to this because of time but i
would just want to point out that
i
i've taken throughout this talk
homophily as a fact of existence of
human existence and certainly there are
a lot of explanations that are things
that we should try to address about
behavioral norms around racism and
hatred and these these sorts of things
but i think that homophily will always
be with us because there are some in
fact rational explanations for him
awfully namely if i talk to people that
are more similar to me i get
more information about the the truth the
underlying truth and so uh this is based
on joint work with divya
and nica who are here and shuchi who
i mean uh brandon who will visit so yeah
if you want to hear more about this
ask ask one of us um
but in the interest of time
i will skip to the conclusion where i
want to point out that i i discussed how
homophily exists the the fact that
homophily you know i defined what
homophobia was this tendency for humans
to seek out those that are similar to
them took it as a fact that this exists
and pointed out that this has profound
impacts on society even though it feels
like a very local personal thing it can
have global consequences
both in
we explored in this talk
homophily and geographical segregation
and housing markets and also its impact
on inequality and mobility and
productivity in labor markets
and sort of a
like another zooming out uh this is the
an institute for theoretical computer
science and i think it's very important
to
first continue to pursue theoretical
results about social systems and why is
that because i believe that theoretical
work will shed lights on the mechanisms
at play in these social systems and
thereby allow us to address
design policies to address them thank
you
uh thanks for a really nice talk uh i
had a question about the first half
about
the housing uh one theoretical one
practical uh the theoretical is
the sorts of the kind of like
uh the sort of uh
behavior in the subcritical case uh
where you kind of have these like things
spreading reminds me
on a very vague level of other dynamical
systems things like sand pile models are
there other dynamical systems that you
know that behave in similar ways and i
mean only at a very squishy level that
might be real that might be an even
simpler version of what's happening
yeah so the question was whether there
are other dynamical systems that exhibit
these kinds of
models where some phenomena spreads
virally throughout the system
and
i guess you could kind of
consider
certain information uh policies and
social networks to have this type of
property of course now it depends very
much on how you define the dynamical
system but um you know how does news
become viral would be
you could set up models in which you
could explain the virality of certain
types of mutes and it would have this
sort of feature that it just swarms out
other stuff existing in the system we
also saw this a little bit in the uh
in the
when he
presented uh his work on
uh
that was based on the work of morris on
how products spread how like adoption of
products spread and so some product can
become viral if
people want to adopt it when the
majority of their neighbors have adopted
it so yeah i can i can point you to some
other systems that do this but it is an
interesting phenomenon i don't know
anything about sand files barely even do
i so
and then
and then on the more practical side
has there has there is there data that
suggests this sort of spread happens in
practice
so yeah then the question was do we see
this sort of um
segregation in cities and practice and
i think
there's so people have tried to fit
these models to
segregation and like
uh was in his job market paper was
looking at uh these models to
help explain segregation in chicago
where you see things like white flight
people like to call it um
but yeah and there's there's a whole
another interesting piece of all of this
which is we should believe that that
this is
at play in practice
there's a lot i don't understand about
modeling but i wanted to ask them about
the the number tau in the first half
isn't it clear that
that it wouldn't be just one number that
there'd be a distribution that would be
a distribution
and that not only would there be a
distribution but there might be some
generalizations to be made about how
green circles and blue triangles might
have a different distribution for tap
and that that would affect the
segregation behavior so the question was
about
the tolerance of individuals
in the housing market
section and if individuals have
different tolerances some are more
tolerant than others could this impact
the outcomes so
there's
one aspect of this is what if there's
you know it's not correlated with type
but people might
some people might be happier with more
integrated neighborhoods than others um
and for that you know i think you can
see from sort of the intuitions i gave
that so long as
most of the people still fall in this
what i was calling sub-critical regime
the same kind of dynamics will
persist
but the other
element of the question was what if it
is correlated with type and maybe blue
circles are more tolerant than green
triangles
uh then
there has been some work on this showing
that um
like you can get complete takeover by
the
less tolerant type
so i have two questions
the first question is shelling
segregation seems to be studying a
spatial segregation or their models or
papers are studying temporal segregation
since they're fixing the same location
there are certain hours of the day the
black population is hanging out there
more
there are certain hours of data
the question was about temporal
segregation um i don't quite see the
mathematical distinction in that
i might okay so i might change the
network structure but i should be able
to map each hour of the day to a
location in a network where
like
there's a clique on the hours that
everybody spends half a day at the pool
there's a clique on the
hours that are within half a day of each
other and
so so i would try to address this
question doing something like that
um
so then the question would translate to
uh are there like
i think for hours in a day you could
even look at it as a line or a ring if
you like
a more general question that i think
you're asking implicitly is what about
other networks i just looked at one and
two d lattices of you know higher 3d
lattices
but more general networks i'm not aware
of a lot of work that looks at
generic
underlying network structures i think in
part because you have to come up with a
story as to why you care about that
network structure and notice that
there's something that we're trading
here in the sense that i'm moving out of
my house and you move into my house and
thereby inherit the
neighbors that i had before
right so that dynamic and has to be
motivated in whatever you're thinking
about as well as the network structure
and then my second question is about the
second part of the cloud so
when you think about
referrals they seem to be sent out
simultaneously
for example
uh if i wanna refer someone i can ask
that person whether he or she has been
already returned by someone else
yes i'm gonna take someone else from
your fandom among the
people that are in my network
so the question was about the timing of
referrals and the timing of hiring of
course hiring is
in many not all but many labor markets
it's somewhat continuous um over time
and so
uh you could imagine
like i i might
not wake up and
when i wake up to refer somebody the one
i was going to refer to was already made
an offer i can move on to prefer someone
else
um
this
is
not something i've thought about
before but i i think that
if you have this complete homophily and
you have a lot of employment it's just
going to cause
it won't fix the problem because you're
going to get still all the blues are
going to be getting
like half half the population who have
is going to get two-thirds of the
referrals
so
there are i think things that continuous
hiring might change in particular that
we are sort of
hooked up counter example to affirmative
action relied on the
timing of the hiring being
kind of
encyclopedias but i don't think it will
fix the main problem that i was
interested in all right so i'm going to
take one more question and this will be
the one online question that we have so
um
do you think that homophily has a
negative impact on academic and
scholarly networks insofar as it may
lead to the formation of close groups of
scientists that are less open to free
exchange of ideas and the pursuit of
novel evidence of research
um so
sergio bellos okay so sergio what
godless is asking online if uh
homophily in academic networks is
problematic for science i guess as a
summary of the question
and
i think that there could be
a lot of issues with
so i think homophobically okay so this
is actually a good
question because i i we sort of think of
segregation in cities for example as
being bad
but i don't think that homophobia or
segregation is inherently bad i think
that
it's nice to be in a place where you
feel welcomed and like a part of a thing
i think what's bad is if you don't have
these sort of bridge types and so
i think academia definitely suffers from
this like we i how many
trump supporters do you know in your
departments
right and like by
eliminating that or suppressing that
element i think we're losing a lot of
of
diversity of ideas and we suppress that
of elements so extremely in academia
that we don't even really have
relationships with these people to to
acquire their ideas and so i
i just see this as being problematic
continue to deception and the cooler